Hey youtubers, what’s up!
This video is going to be a breakdown of this
new trailer but there’s also a shit ton
of news the CW has released.
The Cast of both shows did a big TCA panel
together and talked about new spinoff shows
they’re working on, what’s going on with
the characters and a bunch of other stuff.
Starting with the Arrow footage.
This is just like the Flash trailer I posted
yesterday.
It only covers episode 10 but it sets up the
next mini story arc.
Oliver is gone so Evil rises in the Glades.
Primarily in the form of Vinnie Jones here
who’s playing Brick from the comics.
On the show he’s going to be more of an
enterprising gang leader like Vertigo at the
beginning of the season.
I know everyone is wondering where Vertigo
is.
He will be back in a future episode as part
of Laurel’s Black Canary arc.
I don’t know how that will play out but
Vinnie Jones here is going to be the first
big villain that the new Team Arrow will have
to defeat.
I use the term “New” loosely, it’s really
Team Arrow without Oliver, but
with the addition of Laurel.
We do see Oliver in the trailer, someone is
carry his body to this door.
I had a theory that I think I mentioned in
my episode 9 video that Merlyn would be the
one to save him.
You can see Merlyn in the Arrow Cave placing
the sword on the table.
I think that’s the sword from the mountain
top that Ra’s Al Ghul threw in the ground.
The one with Oliver’s blood on it.
If Merlyn leaves to come bring the sword back
to Starling, that means someone else is taking
care of Oliver back here in this place.
I think it’s probably Maseo.
But I wouldn’t be surprised if Nyssa also
helps him.
I wonder if the sword still has his blood
on it.
Like Merlyn gives it to them so they can analyze
his blood and know Merlyn is telling the truth.
I also posted a theory video about Merlyn
being a hero of sorts in the back half.
I don’t think he’s going to be a white
knight type of hero but I’d say saving Oliver
on the mountain top qualifies.
I think a lot of people were confused by what
I said too.
I also said I think Merlyn will be straight
up evil by the end of the season, it’s just
that for the short term, this next mini-arc.
He’ll help Team Arrow more than he hurts
them.
Ray Palmer also going to be one of the more
obvious heros of the back half of the season
testing out part of his Atom Suit here.
They announced at the TCAs that The CW is
working on an ATOM Spin Off show for his character.
Originally the plan was for him to guest star
on The Flash Season 2.
Because he’s a scientist, he naturally fits
in with that Star Labs crowd.
But there’s this big shift happening behind
the scenes at the CW.
The network itself.
They’re doubling down on their comic book
tv shows.
Meaning they’re developing another spinoff
for Arrow, that’s the ATOM show and The
Flash, that would be Robbie Amell’s Firestorm
character.
In addition, there’s a new animated Arrow
show that will be digital only.
It will center on Vixen.
Marc Guggenheim, the Showrunner on Arrow will
oversee it.
It is connected to Arrow but think of it the
same way you think of the Animated Marvel
and DC shows.
Her superpower will be a little like Animal
Man’s.
She’ll be able to take on the abilities
of one animal at a time.
Oliver and Barry will appear in it so you
should expect Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin
to do their voices.
The reason the CW is pushing for all these
extra new comic books shows on top of what
they’ve already got is because the affiliate
network they have their big contract with
is rumored to be unhappy with their current
programming.
It’s been suggested that before Arrow and
The Flash, the CW was largely a network that
catered to a female audience.
And the affiliates felt like that wasn’t
broad enough.
Meaning they wanted more shows that males
ages 18-34 would watch.
Which equals more male driven superhero shows.
Which is why the CW is developing an ATOM
show, a Firestorm show.
And so on.
They’ll probably have more news about those
at Comic Con this summer but I’m not expecting
either of those to debut right away.
It would be crazy if they had two extra new
shows by the end of this year.
It’s reasonable to expect if they do end
up making both those new spinoff shows, they’d
premiere in 2016.
I don’t want to speculate too much because
they only just said, yes we are working on
making new spinoffs.
The next big news item is crossovers.
Each year they’ll do a new crossover episode.
Just like the last one, it will be in the
fall.
Before the mid-season finales of both shows.
And yes, the new Supergirl show
on CBS will also cross over with Arrow and
The Flash.
There’s a rumor that Greg Berlanti has a
clause in his contract that allowed him to
do crossovers.
Which I think is funny.
Tom Cavanagh confirmed he is one of the Reverse
Flashes, he didn’t say which one.
But Andrew Kreisberg also confirmed Eddie
Thawne is connected to the Reverse Flash lore
of the comics.
Here’s what I think is going on.
In episode 9.
I think there are two people here and both
of them are harrison wells.
Two separate versions of Harrison Wells and
they’re working together.
Otherwise how would he have gotten his hands
on the device.
I still think that Eddie Thawne will become
another version of the Reverse Flash, I just
think that Eddie Thawne is the first version
of the Reverse Flash and Harrison Wells is
his descendant.
Harrison needs Barry to achieve his potential,
so the real quesiton we need to ask now is
why.
What is it that Barry does that shapes the
future in the way that Harrison wants.
Harrison’s sessions with Gideon make it
clear he’s trying to shape the future in
a particular way.
And yes, Morena Baccarin is the voice of Gideon.
She’s the
voice of the computer.
She said recently that we’d see more Gideon
this year.
Lots of stuff to think about.
Here’s my big question for you guys.
What part of all this news are you most excited
about.
Flash Season 2?
New Spinoffs?
I’m totally going to have to hire an assistant
with all these new shows I’m going to be
making videos for.
The next big thing next week in addition to
a new episode of Gotham is a new Avengers
Trailer.
I’ll be posting that Monday Night.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’m expecting there to be new footage.
While you wait for that, click here to watch
the new Flash Trailer and Click here to learn
about the next couple of episodes on Arrow.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!